Since.
The beginning of game of Thrones,
the show felt like it could never end in the book.
Present shock Douglas Rushkoff uses the show's opening title sequence as an
allegory to this problem.
The camera pans over an animated map of the entire world of the saga,
showing the various divisions and cleanse within the empire.
It is drawn in the style of a fantasy role-playing math used by participants as
the game board for their battles and intrigues and like a fantasy role-playing
game. The show is not about grating, satisfying resolutions,
but rather about keeping the adventure life and as many threads going as
possible. There is plot, there are many plots,
but there is no overarching story. No end. There are so many plants.
In fact that an ending tying everything up seems inconceivable.
Even beside the points.
Rushkoff definitely has a point.
The best word to describe the earlier seasons of the show would probably be
chaotic main characters,
die at a moment's notice and plots meander in many different directions.
And that's part of the appeal of game of Thrones.
It's exciting to experience a world where the present moment is so
unpredictable,
but what Rushkoff fails to mention is the narrative hidden beneath the surface
of all that present chaos in reality game of Thrones does have a story.
It is the story of characters traumatized by the past,
shocked in the present and looking for a future to believe in. Yes,
the world of game of Thrones is defined by chaos,
but many characters in game of Thrones are not they're instead defined by their
struggle to find a story within the world. They exist in.
There's no episode that makes this distinction better than in the season six
finale. The winds of winter, the episode shows us characters,
trying to make sense of the world in many different ways.
By putting them all together.
This episode becomes a metaphor for the entire series as a whole.
It is the symbolic end of the chaotic era of game of Thrones from seasons one
through six.
And at the beginning of its attempt of finding meaning within that chaos
Episode begins with the biggest act of chaos in the show's entire run up to this
point, the destruction of the set of Baylor.
This sequence leads up to an act of terrorism orchestrated by Searcy Lannister,
the character who most embodies the chaos and cynicism present in the game of
Thrones world. Up to this point,
she and her family have been responsible for the show's most significant
discontinuity in its linear narrative.
She and her son had the show's main character killed in the ninth episode.
She and her father had more main characters killed in the red wedding and she
herself has lost all attachment to the future. After two of her children died,
suddenly she gave up on preserving anything other than herself,
and those immediately loyal to her.
We can therefore see her destruction of the set of Baylor,
along with the religious hierarchy, political rivals,
and many more main characters as the ultimate act of chaos.
Not only does she destroy the literal embodiment of belief in the seven
kingdoms, but she does it.
Because it felt good to watch them burn.
Good to imagine that shock and pain.
Searcy doesn't destroy the Sept because she has some plot for world domination.
She does it because she feels she has nothing left to lose.
And when someone has nothing to lose,
they can risk everything to end up on top Marjorie,
a character with just as much political savvy as Searcy is the only one in the
[inaudible].
So has he understands the consequences of her absence she's absent anyway,
which means she does not intend to suffer those consequences.
The other characters are so blinded in their belief,
in the sanctity of religious traditions,
that they couldn't fathom the possibility that Searcy wouldn't show up for the
trial, much less retaliate with violence.
Searcy cynicism is an advantage while others cling to their beliefs,
she decides to embrace the chaos and protect herself.
Her destruction of the set is the epitome of the chaotic worlds of game of
Thrones. Ironically,
this act of chaos is also the beginning of a more linear ending to the show.
It gets rid of multiple important characters and ends a major plot line that has
dominated the show for the last two seasons. Thus,
the show begins its shift from a chaotic and meandering character study to an
ending oriented and plot focus to TV drama.
The winds of winter begins with the familiar chaos of game of Thrones,
but the rest of the episode shows us something unfamiliar characters,
banding together, getting revenge and realizing their destinies.
Um, to be the new master.
This episode focuses on wrap-up of various characters, plot lines,
a further attempt at bringing an end to the chaos Jamie's military campaign
ends. Sam reaches old town Melisandre is cast away Jon and Sansa resolved their
tension and some unlikely alliances form.
As we landed Marine with Denaris the show points towards some finality and
progress.
Walton Aeris has spent the entire show in SOC growing as a leader and as a
character, she was always going to return to Westeros, to reclaim the throne,
her conversation with Darrio Novaris shows us she is finally ready to take this
crucial step in her personal narrative.
Denaris his whole life story has been about her,
right to the iron throne while Searcy desires,
power out of a desire for self-preservation Denaris fights for the throne
because of a belief in destiny.
To walk. My birthright is seven kingdoms of Western.
Her right to rule comes from a belief in a story about succession,
but Searcy rules because she tore down those beliefs.
This is why Tyrian decides to support Denaris.
So I said, no, thank you to believe.
And yet here I am.
I believe in you.
Tyrian a self-proclaimed Sinek son of the most cold-hearted politician in
Westeros Ann's brother of Searcy herself finds his faith into an Eris.
Her potential rule offers a restoration from the chaos brought by his family,
and it is why she is central to this story.
She hopes to restore the stories and institutions undone by civil Wars and
cynical Lords. Back in Westeros, we get another satisfying Arias,
revenge murder of Walder Frey for his portrayal of her family.
This scene shows a different solution to the chaos.
The last thing you're ever going to see is a stock smiling down at you as you
die.
It's a satisfying moment in game of Thrones because this type of justice is so
rare. The idea of justice itself is a story. It requires cause and effect,
and the writing of Iran while Searcy's retribution at the start of this episode
was explosive and indiscriminate Arias retribution is incisive and personal.
Then in Winterfeld the Lord of chaos himself,
Peter Baelish speaks with Sansa by the werewolf tree Sansar remarks on her
growth from a naive aspiring princess to cynical ward Innes of the North.
Like then I initial smells. I wanted never, I had.
The most prominent victim of chaos in the show.
Her multiple traumas have created a discontinuity in her personal narrative
while she wants prayed and wanted to become a princess, the horse,
she has been subjected to have crushed her belief in stories and Tappy endings
like Searcy and little finger. This cynicism is her advantage,
but even in such a hopeless character,
the show manages to find her something to believe in a way to end her trauma and
finish her story. Setting this scene in the gods would hints at that one.
Last thing that Sansa believes.
I love the future of how stark her family.
Finally.
We see the immensely consequential vision of John's true parentage leading into
the scene where he is declared King in the North.
The John is the rightful heir to the iron throne.
Heritage is not the basis of his leadership like it is for Denaris nor is it
simply because he killed his enemies like Searcy.
While these things are a part of it,
they only matter because he could unite the disparate houses under a single
banner without this popular approval John's rule would be just another chaotic
plot line.
But they're overwhelming support shows that people will put chaos and cynicism
aside to fight for a common cause something rare for the series.
John is able to do this because he gave the Northern Lord something beyond the
present to believe in his warnings of white walkers and the army of the dead,
motivated them to put rivalries on hold, to fight a common enemy.
John represents an alternative to chaos and to restoring old stories.
So at the end of the winds of winter,
we have two opposed coronations and another would be ruler on the way one who
represents the chaos of a world without a story.
Another who promises to restore an old story and a third who offers a different
story entirely at its core game of Thrones has been a story about people finding
ways to survive in an uncertain world,
learning to trust in one another to fight for common causes and to
reconstructing a new narrative in a world without any.
But before this finale episode,
the show was more about people finding their way through the present chaos.
And after this episode,
it became about pushing characters towards a future that wrapped up the past as
Thrones moved towards a world,
driven by story and away from a world driven by chaos.
It had to make a complete shift,
no longer focusing on the exciting and watchable present chaos.
Of course the show had to end sometime,
but endings are in a way against everything that made game of Thrones special in
the first place. Nonetheless, it's the fantasy.
We've all been indulging in for the last decade because it speaks to a universal
struggle. So don't be sad how the show ends because in reality,
there's no time like the present.
[Inaudible].
In present shock.
Rushkoff sometimes sounds pretty pessimistic about the current cultural
landscape. He stresses how technology traps us in the presence,
not letting ideas and thoughts half the time they need to settle.
The cruel irony of this issue is that the internet does give us the opportunity
to learn and consume in a productive way.
If you're doing something that takes time and effort like writing your own
story, the internet gives you access to the best stories like Daniel,
Jose older,
a New York times best-selling author who has his own class on storytelling on
Skillshare. I think Skillshare is helping solve,
present shock with their online selection of over 25,000 classes in creative
writing,
video editing and more premium membership gives you the opportunity to really
spend time joining classes and communities that match your exact goals.
Click on the link in the description below for your chance at two months,
to try it out for free that's access to Daniel Jose alters class,
plus thousands of others across a wide range of topics,
a big thank you to Skillshare and also a big thank you to my Patrion supporters
who make this channel possible. I couldn't do it without you.
And if you like what you saw,
keep watching the other great videos in this playlist.
And if you didn't like what you saw, watch the other ones anyway,
cause he might like them better.